We're matching!!!
Marzia: YEAH!
Marzia: What do you get? Yay you got pins too!
WE BOTH GOT PINS!
Hell yeah, looks so cool
Squad goals
Couple goals
All kinds of- WE'RE GOING TO SCARE PEWDIEPIE
How much are you gonna bet, that they're going to
make a big deal about me having these on
I swear to god, they're all gonna point it out
Erm... everyone has been freaking out all morning
because it was a 10am instead of 1pm
So...
We have to hurry the fuck up
This vlog is probably not gonna be
your typical vlog
Well, well, well
Look who it is
What are you doing?
You guys look good
You should stay there
I'm going in the car now
BYE
Hey guys, I got a surprise for you
HAHAHAHA!
Michael: Maaaan
Brad: You're fucking mad man
Yeah thanks for giving me the ammo back
How you doing there BRAD
Michael: KILL HIM
Brad: I HAVE A WIFE AND A KID
Brad: I GOT KIDS MAN
GIVE ME YOUR MONEY
Brad: AHHH!
Thanks buddy
GET HIM
YOU'VE BEEN DOUBLE CROSSED
I GOT MORE AMMO BOY
Brad: AHHH
AHHHHHHH
AHHHH YOU SHOT ME IN THE FUCKING HAT
WHAT THE HELL IS WRONG WITH YOU
YOU SHOT ME IN THE CHIN
OH I know that scene
So you're the one the boss keeps talking about
OHHH
I ALMOST SHOT THE DRIVER
I'M SORRY
JESUS CHRIST
Don't you dare
Marzia: The nipple? Felix: Shoot my nipple.
OHHHH
OHHHHH
(some nice music comes on)
What are you guys doing? Blacken out the window
Why  do you look so suspicious Michael?
What's gonna happen?
Michael: I KNOW A THING, but I can't tell you
Well, then don't
So it's your first day on Scare Pewdiepie
How do you feel? Excited?
Marzia: Yeah, I have a headache but-
This is all you dreamt about?
Marzia: I really- Yeah I mean it's beautiful colour
Marzia: I think-
What the fuck?
Are you doing?
Brad: YEAH DAMN
Michael: IT HURTS, STOP
Michael: I, I, I played the Life is Strange yesterday and I was thinking
How can she GET-
OHHHHHHH
WOAHHHH
Life is strange taught Michael
How to be strong
(more music)
Herro?
Oh, what is this?
EWWW HUH HEWW
Bonjour
Bonsoir
Tu t'appelles comment ? ("What's your name ?")
Welcome, to cooking with "PedroPie"
Today, we are going to make
Cheese it, banana
You grab one cheese its, I MEAN BANANA
YOU TAKE
Cheese its
You Stick it in the banana
It gives that crunchyness
Its very good
Taste like cheese
who doesnt like cheese
And a banana
An also if you feel wierd really crazy
You can get uuhh.. my accent is already gone
(laughs)
ohhh..
Oh look at that banana
very naice
Oh its very beautiful
Looks just like brad's penis
This is the finest
This is straight from a pigs butthole
You stick it in you stick it in like
That
Just stick it just stick it
In like ohh....
oh
oh thats good...
(music)
And there you have
A felix delight
(yum)
(EW)
HMM ITS GOOD?
(regret)
Very nice
This is what we did in sweden when we where in high school
You take a pound
(most of the countries do that)
You do it like this
And you have to keep it on
So you have to do that keep it on
FUCK
FUCK!
So you have to put your knuckle down so i get to shoot it
What the fuck?
Brad: I didn't agree to this.
yea you did ;)
Brad is going down bitch
hes gonna flick it in my eyes
Its gonna flick it in my eyes
watch
(it flew)
ohhhhh
FUCK!
OOOOOHHHH
Come on
Not so close
(fatality)
(scream)
In dick
ohhh you fuken suck
Ohhh you fuken suck
Get him get him
Put it down properly
it is down properly
It is down properly
(scream)
(laughs)
JESUS
SHIIIIIT
oh that was a close one
Oh that was a close one
Uh no no
He hit me there
But it doesnt look like here
Its wierd doesnt like show up anyways
It doesnt look like how it hurts it really hurts
(shouting)
DO IT
No dont you
Im not cheating i promis
Why is it taking so long
uh
Watch the nut dude
(laughs)
(music while playing dangerous games)
Wow look at that so you love norway
This is disgusting!
How dare you!
I didnt do it
Who did this?
You did this?
I mean i may have?
My own girlfriend!
Hey captain sparkles is here
Hey its captain sparkles....
Im looking fabulous i hope
Oh i got new socks
i like how there is just water in your shoe
We are flying out just before thanks giving so we are celebrating thanksgiving today
we are flying out just before thanks giving so we are celebrating thanksgiving today
Happy thanks giving!
(i thought its captainsparkles not turkeysparkles)
Eat
(damn he likes the taste of captain sparkles)
You wanna pray?
What?
pray to the turkey
Pray to the turkey
(turkey praying)
They dont know how to say pray
How does it look?
Do i look sad?
Looks look sad
now just look normal
Now just look normal
(laughs)
Wait its gonna be like this
Its gonna be like papias
I've got something to tell you guys
(fake crying)
that was so sad
That was so sad
what happened to you?
What happened to you?
Michael is so ugly
I cant deal with it
I cant deal
With it
I think he fucked with the shirt
(laughs)
Brad
I think
Oh i think this is
pretty wet brad
Pretty wet brad
what do you think?
What do you think?
Thanks brad you got a strike
yea i want the strike now leave me alone
Yeah i want the strike now leave me alone
(laughs)
Man i look good in this mustache man
I mean...
Should i keep this look?
Leave a like if you agree
NO
no
Strip it!
NO
Not my penis
Oh you are not wearing the shirt
NOOOO
I feel like this mustache needs a name like "PedroPie"
Hola
Hola brochachas
Me llamo es "PedroPie" (I'm called is "PedroPie")
(music)
Oh my god who did that
This is just here
Marzia: oh my god!
who put that there
Oh my god!
Who put that there
oh my god its so cute
So cute
thats so creepy
Thats so creepy
We've away the whole day and we had the doors locked
The door was locked
Who did this?
Is it uh?
Its a piñata !
Its a trump piñata isnt it?
Its a trump piñata
Its a PedroPie
tomorrow on the election day
Tomorrow on the election day
tomorrow is the election day we're gonna have some fun with
Tomorrow is the election day we're gonna have some fun with
I guess he can sleep with pedro for now
i mean
oh, THAT FITS PERFECT!
I mean
Oh
hell yea
Hell yea
Woah trump
woah trump
trumpy trump
Trumpy trump
hold it
Hold it
man that was such a fun day
Man that was such a fun day
These shoots for the scare pewdiepie are amazing
these shoots for the scare pewdiepie are amazing
Compared to first season, it's so much better
It's like ten times better
I'm really excited for you guys to see it
I'm having a lot of fun shooting them at least
They're very long days but..
and to do the vlogs at the same time
like everyone is working really hard ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
to get these out every single day so I hope you really enjoy them
You better, is what i'm trying to say...
You better fucking enjoy them
You hear my voice, i'm yelling all day
good fun though
PedroPie
(laughs)
Oh fuck I forgot I have these fucking mustache
Looks awesome
(laughs)
I'm...I'm working it
I'm working it
You love it!
What the hell is all this?
Felix... this is definitely from a fan
Great package
This is creepy
Do you see what it says?
Marzia: How did they bring it here?
(Reads) Think about vlogging
(Reads) and realize how easy
(Reads) people are gonna find their address
I don't like that
I don't think that's funny
Marzia: that's why you pull me on my vlogs
I know they're trying to be funny but it's not funny
I think people think it's like
trolly or like..
they have some sort of power over you
like I see people put the address and they're like
(stupid voice) Oh look i found their address guys
(stupid voice) oh oh oh
and like
ok
you're fucking creepy and weird like
I don't know
This...
In the trashhhh
This is what you get when you have an italian girlfriend
Marzia: That's mine, change place
oh well i guess that's not mine..
Thank you Marzia for cooking, i know you're tired
(Italian accent) I get the pasta
(Italian accent) with the italian girlfriend
Marzia: You have to mix it!
(Italian accent) I have to mix it otherwise is not italian
Allright, that's the end of another Birdabo
Tomorrow is election day
I'm just here dropping a footage to Brad
In case it hasn't clicked already
Brad and Michael are helping me editing while I'm here
I really owe them a huge thanks for
all the stuff they do
I just do the final cut pretty much
I was really freaking out before I came here
and I really appreciate that they come over
'cause I don't know what to do with the vlogs
but i'm just so happy that you guys are enjoying them so much
I really appreciate all the nice comments
and all the feedbacks, it's really exciting for me
to-
to be making something that so many people really appreciate
rather than mine standard kind of stuff so...
I couldn't be happier about it
So thank you guys
so much
thanks for leaving a like
Keep showing your support and
I'll see you bros
tomorrow
with another birdabo
we get some exciting stuff coming up then
Stay awesome bros
(music)
Bye guys, see you in the next video :)
(why are you still here honestly?)
omg
get out
jk tho <3
What if I don't want to? (peace bro)
no(yes)?
(bye)